oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Premier ministre monsieur mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
le 10 janvier dernier madame la Première
ministre vous avez présenté votre enfin
votre projet de réforme des retraites en
vous fixant comme objectif de sauver les
retraites par répartition et vous avez
raison ce débat ne pouvait pas être
reporté il était irresponsable de ne pas
débattre de ce sujet et nous avons
l'intention de le faire c'est invité
dans ce débat
dès maintenant un acteur qui avait été
négligé c'est le déclin démographique de
notre pays
820 000 naissances en 2012 il y a 10 ans
720 000 en 2022 une diminution de cent
mille en disant et toutes les années
nous aurons ces enfants en moins il est
vraisemblable et là que le mouvement se
prolonge nous avons pourtant en effet le
meilleur taux de fécondité d'Europe mais
il n'assure pas le renouvellement et il
a perdu 10% en disant nous avons un taux
un désir d'enfant chez les femmes et
chez les hommes d'ailleurs qui qui
restent élevés mais
53% des mers nous déclarent selon une
étude de l'UNAF qu'il y a qu'elles
auraient été mis à voir plus d'enfants
ma question est très simple madame la
Première ministre
allez-vous vous résigner à ce naufrage
qui comprennent
définitivement le régime par répartition
[Applaudissements]